[Music]
[Applause]
why is it so dark
probably would have been a good idea to
have like one light on the sequel to the
extremely popular
shazam won't be released until 2023
but there's already a first short teaser
for the dc adventure
it shows the eponymous main character
zachary levi in a new outfit
what's new about it is the significantly
smaller lighting bolt on his chest as
well as the much sleeker design of the
suit
a clear improvement in our eyes of
course the question arises as to
why the superhero who's actually just a
super power belly batson
has been given a new look many are also
surprised that shazam doesn't seem to be
wearing his cape anymore
which either means that he has taken it
off or that it will be inserted via cgi
in post-production director david f
sandberg had no precise answer either he
simply posted that the rather early
shooting is
already in progress perhaps however this
is simply a reaction to the many critics
of the original suit who felt the design
was trashy as well as puffy
in their eyes another glimpse can be
found on the page just jared which
actually has their first unofficial set
photos of the superhero up its leaf
we appreciate the early start of filming
and look forward to the release on june
2nd
2023
[Music]